you'd have to be one tough and hungry
animal to try to make a meal out of a
venomous western diamondback rattlesnake
after all this North American desert
dweller is one of the most dangerous
snakes in the world
it's bite is loaded with hemotoxic venom
and this can cause considerable pain and
tissue damage in any creature it sinks
its fangs into enter the red-tailed hawk
with a wingspan reaching nearly 5 feet
it's one of the largest Hawk species in
the world the vertebra wastes no time it
swoops right in to make a quick meal out
of the snake the rattler is instantly
unguarded
it sounds its trademark warning signal
now check out this Matador move
the red-tailed hawk is trying to divert
the Rattler get it to strike at its wing
feathers and expose its head the hawk
chokes the rattler and digs in its
talons the issue of which animal is the
superior predator is quickly established
the hawk makes short work of the rattler
and short work produces a long enjoyable
meal
[Music]